HELP, ALONG WITH MORE POPUPS AND
MOBILE VACCINATION UNITS.
>>> IN AFGHANISTAN, TALIBAN
FORCES ARE LAUNCHING A MAJOR
OFFENSIVE TRYING TO SEIZE AS
MUCH OF THE COUNTRY AS POSSIBLE.
THIS COMES AS U.S. TROOPS BEGIN
TO PULL OUT OF THE COUNTRY AFTER
NEARLY 20 YEARS OF FIGHTING.
AFGHANISTAN IS ONE OF MANY
TOPICS ROBERT GATES DISCUSSES IN
HIS BOOK "EXERCISE OF POWER:
AMERICAN FAILURES, SUCCESSES,
AND A NEW PATH FORWARD IN THE
POST-COLD WAR WORLD."
IT'S NOW OUT IN PAPERBACK.
GATES SERVED AS DEFENSE
SECRETARY UNDER FORMER
PRESIDENTS GEORGE W. BUSH AND
BARACK OBAMA AND JOINS US FIRST
ON "CBS THIS MORNING."
GOOD MORNING, MR. SECRETARY.
THANKS FOR BEING WITH US.
>> GOOD MORNING.
MY PLEASURE.
>> YOU FAMOUSLY SAID IN YOUR
MEMOIR, SIR, THAT MR. BIDEN HAS
BEEN WRONG ON NEARLY EVERY MAJOR
FOREIGN POLICY AND NATIONAL
SECURITY ISSUE OVER THE LAST
FOUR DECADES.
IS HE WRONG ON THIS ONE, TOO?
>> NOT NECESSARILY.
I THINK I WOULD HAVE PROBABLY
AGREED WITH SECRETARY AUSTIN AND
THE JOINTHIEFS IN RECOMMENDING
KEEPING A SMALL GROUP OF 2,500
OR SO U.S. FORCES JUST TO
BOLSTER THE AFGHAN FORCES.
BUT THE TRUTH IS EVEN WITH THOSE
FORCES THERE, AS YOU'VE JUST
POINTED OUT, THE TALIBAN ARE
MAKING INCREASING GAINS IN
AFGHANISTAN.
THEY CONTROL MORE AND MORE OF
THE COUNTRYSIDE WITH EACH
PASSING DAY.
YOU KNOW, OF ALL THE POSSIBLE
ENDINGS IN THIS SITUATION, A
HAPPY ONE IS THE LEAST LIKELY.
I THINK RIGHT NOW THE DECISION
THAT HAS TO BE MADE AND IS
CRITICAL IS TO CONTINUE ECONOMIC
AND MILITARY ASSISTANCE, MEANING
SECURITY ASSISTANCE TO THE
AFGHAN GOVERNMENT.
YOU KNOW, THE SOVIET INSTALLED
GOVERNMENT LASTED FOR THREE
YEARS AFTER THE SOVIETS LEFT,
AND IT WAS ONLY WHEN THE SOVIET
UNION COLLAPSED AND ALL THAT
MILITARY AND ECONOMIC ASSISTANCE
STOPPED THAT THE GOVERNMENT
COLLAPSED.
SO IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT NOW
THAT THE PRESIDENT'S MADE THIS
DECISION WHI I THINK IS A
REASONABLE DECISION UNDER THE
CIRCUMSTANCES TO KEEP THE
ECONOMIC AND SECURITY ASSISTANCE
FLOWING TO AFGHANISTAN, BOTH
FROM OURSELVES AND OUR ALLIES.
THAT'S THE ONLY PRAYER I THINK
THIS GOVERNMENT IN AFGHANISTAN
HAS.
>> AT THE SAME TIME, YOU WRITE
THAT AFGHANISTAN CAN HARDLY BE
CONSIDERED A SUCCESS STORY.
IS THERE ANYTHING WE CAN -- FOR
US, IS THERE ANYTHING WE CAN DO
TO MAKE IT A SUCCESS STORY?
>> WELL, AT THIS POINT, IT KIND
OF DEPENDS ON HOW THE STORY
PLAYS OUT.
AND IF THIS GOVERNMENT IS ABLE
TO SURVIVE AND IF WOMEN ARE ABLE
TO REMAIN ACTIVE AND SOCIAL IN
BUSINESS AND GOVERNMENT LIFE AS
THEY HAVE BECOME, IF GIRLS ARE
ALLOWED TO STAY IN SCHOOL, THAT
WOULD BE AN OUTCOME THAT WE
COULD POINT TO THAT WOULD SAY
THE COUNTRY'S BETTER FOR OUR
HAVING BEEN THERE.
BUT RIGHT NOW OUR EFFORTS TO
BUILD A DIFFERENT KIND OF
COUNTRY IN AFGHANISTAN ARE
LOOKING PRETTY GRIM.
>> SECRETARY GATES, IT'S GOOD TO
SEE YOU AGAIN.
YOU HAVE CALLED PRESIDENT TRUMP
A DIVIDER IN THE COUNTRY.
BUT HE'S STILL A VERY KEY FIGURE
IN THE REPUBLICAN PARTY.
NOW THE REPUBLICAN PARTY APPEARS
TO BE VERY DEEPLY DIVIDED, AS
WELL.
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS AS YOU'RE
WATCHING THIS DISARRAY PLAY OUT?
>> WELL, FIRST OF ALL, I THINK
THAT DIVISIONS WITHIN PARTIES
ARE NOTHING NEW AMONG BOTH
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS.
AND THOSE DIVISIONS CAN BE
HEALTHY AS LONG AS THEY'RE
FOCUSED ON PROGRAMS AND
POLICIES.
IT'S WHEN YOU GET FOCUSSED ON
PERSONALITIES THAT I THINK THEY
-- THESE DIFFERENCES HAVE THE
POTENTIAL TO BECOME A KIND OF A
CIRCULAR FIRING SQUAD.
AND I DON'T THINK THAT DOES THE
PARTY ANY GOOD AT ALL.
>> THESE DIVISIONS DON'T SEEM
ALSO TO BE BASED ON FACTS.
YOU KNOW THAT OLD SAYING,
EVERYONE'S ENTITLED TO YOUR
OPINION, BUT YOU'RE NOT ENTITLED
TO YOUR FACTS, YOUR OWN SET OF
FACTS.
AND THE POINT IS THAT THERE ARE
STILL MANY PEOPLE WHO BELIEVE
THAT THIS ELECTION WAS NOT FAIR
AND SQUARE.
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, THAT'S
TROUBLING.
I MEAN, MAYBE THAT'S AN
UNDERSTATEMENT.
>> YEAH.
>> BUT YOU KNOW, WE'VE GOT TO
START AT SOME POINT FROM THE
SAME UNDERSTANDING OF REALITY.
NOW HOW TO AFFECT THAT REALITY
AND CHANGE IT IS WHAT POLITICS
ARE ABOUT.
IF YOU DON'T UNDERSTAND THE
SITUATION YOU'RE IN AND THE
FACTUAL CIRCUMSTANCES THAT GOT
YOU TO WHERE YOU ARE, I THINK
YOU'RE BEHIND THE EIGHT BALL.
>> SHOULD THE PRESIDENT GET HIS
-- FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP GET
HIS FACEBOOK PRIVILEGES BACK,
THE DECISION'S GOING TO BE
RELEASED TODAY.
>> THAT'S UP TO THAT FACEBOOK
BOARD.
THAT'S ABOVE MY PAY GRADE.
>> NO, IT'S NOT.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT, IF YOU WANTED
TO BE ON THAT BOARD, THEY ARE
LOOKING FOR ADDITIONAL MEMBERS.
THEY WANT --
>> THAT'S RIGHT --
>> YOU COULD PROBABLY HAVE A
SEAT.
YOU KNOW, LET'S SWITCH GEARS TO
ANOTHER MATTER YOU COULD SAY IS
OF COMPELLING PUBLIC INTEREST.
BIT OF A SMILE, UFOs.IT WITH A
THE PENTAGON, WHICH YOU USED TO
RUN, IS SET TO PUT A REPORT OUT
ON UFOs NEXT MONTH.
HOW SERIOUS IS THIS WITHIN THE
MILITARY WORLD?
ARE THEY REAL?
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS ON THE
SUBJECT OVERALL?
>> YEARS AGO WHEN I WAS
SECRETARY, I HAD A SENATOR COME
TO ME AND -- AND DEEPEST
SECRECY, HE WANTED ME TO GIVE
HIM A BRIEFING ON ALIENS.
AND I SAID, WELL, CIA DOESN'T
HANDLE IMMIGRANTS.
AND HE SAID, NO, NO, I MEAN
ALIENS.
I SAID, OH, YOU MEAN ALIENS.
AND HE SAID, YES.
I SAID -- I COURAGEOUSLY
ANSWERED, WELL, THAT'S THE AIR
FORCE'S PROBLEM.
YOU KNOW, IN ALL SERIOUSNESS, IN
ALL MY YEARS AS DIRECTOR OF
CENTRAL INTELLIGENCE AND
SECRETARY OF DEFENSE, NO ONE
EVER BROUGHT ME ANY EVIDENCE OR
ANY INFORMATION RELATING TO
UFOs, WHICH IS NOT TO SAY
THEY'RE NOT OUT THERE.
AND IT WILL BE INTERESTING TO
SEE WHAT THESE RELEASES HAVE TO
SAY.
>> YOU HAVEN'T HAD ANY SIGHTINGS
YOURSELF, SIR?
>> NO SIGHTINGS UP HERE.
>> OKAY.
SECRETARY GATES, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR JOINING US THIS
MORNING.
WE APPRECIATE IT.
TH